you know the cbc called me up to do this  anniversary thing they want to do a day  in the life deal i thought that was  pretty cool idea and I said all right  let's do it so here I am getting up at  630am because I've got to work with  Heather hiscox right now to do what's  called a warning hit two minutes she's  running the show she brings me in by  Skype you know the thing about the CDC  I'm going to tell you guys is the whole  place is run by women I'm working for  women I'm a token guide their think  about the Heather his costume and a lang  Kirsten Stewart Julie Bristow know all  these are women I work for it's  ridiculous so you know how I get back  out today I want to do that hit by Scott  I won't have any pants on I never do I'm  not kidding  you